bonjour à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui
c'est une vidéo un petit peu
particulière qui sort sur la chaîne
c'est une vidéo que j'ai fait en
collaborant aux dons c'est une vidéo qui
est sorti sur yahoo dans le cadre d'un
programme qui s'appelle yahoo green ou
en gros je pars avec mon pote
fabien qui travaille chez eux et on
traite des thématiques écologiques que
ce soit des catastrophes ou bien des
initiatives donc cette vidéo elle est
déjà sorti sur yahoo mais il ya je pars
il ya plus d'un mois généralement les
vidéos qu'on sort ensemble elles sortent
que là bas
moi je les communique sur mes réseaux et
par exemple pour celle ci je l' ai aussi
fait sur l'onglet communauté mais je
trouve ça vraiment dommage de ne pas lui
donner l'exposition qu'elle mérite à
chaque fois on par fabien et moi et en
plus je trouve que fabien est vraiment
bon en real et celle là elle est cette
vidéo la halle et je la trouve vraiment
stylé vous me direz ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire voilà je voulais
juste pour recontextualiser la chose
donc évidemment c'est une vidéo qui
était tourné bien avant le confinement
je partagerai pas toutes les vidéos que
je tourne avec eux en upload comme ça
sur ma chaîne donc n'hésitez pas à les
suivre sur leur instinct si vous voulez
les voir dès qu'elles sortent love peace
now
on parle beaucoup de changements
climatiques et on oublie souvent de dire
qu'en fait le premier organe de
régulation du climat c'est l'océan le
premier poumon de la planète c'est
l'océan puisqu'il fournit plus de 50% de
l'oxygène qu'on respire quand on se
parle en fait plus d'une inspiration sur
2 comprend on la doit aux animaux marins
donc si l'océan meurent nous mourrons
avec lui et si on n'est pas capable de
sauver les dauphins ont souvent rien
d'autre dans l'océan
[Musique]
en 2019 dans le golfe de gascogne on
estime à 11 mille trois cents le nombre
de dauphins morts
en hiver la population de dauphins dans
nos zones est estimé à 200 milles à
cette vitesse nous mettons tous nos fins
en danger fin janvier nous avons quitté
le port de la rochelle et nous avons
suivi le quotidien delo ong sea shepherd
pendant quatre jours pour mieux
comprendre la situation des dauphins
dans le golfe de gascogne
dans cette vidéo nous allons voir
ensemble ce qui menace les dauphins
comment sea shepherd a décidé de lutter
pour les dauphins et ce qu'il faut
changer pour que ça s'arrête
l'enjeu est immense car effectivement si
nous ne sommes pas capables de prendre
des mesures pour préserver le dauphin
d'un des animaux marins les plus
appréciés sans parler du fait que ce
soit une espèce protégée alors nous ne
seront sûrement pas capable de sauver la
vie marine dans son ensemble
sea shepherd est une ong fondée en 1977
par à paul watson un ancien membre
fondateur de greenpeace l'organisation
est voué à la protection des écosystèmes
avec une devise défendre conservés
protégés ils peuvent parfois être connus
pour leurs procédés d'action directe
comme de l'abordage mais ce n'est pas le
cas de cette campagne dans le golfe de
gascogne appelé dolphin by catch nous
sommes à bord du sam simone avancer un
bateau scientifique japonais
l'équipage compte environ 25 personnes
et c'est une vraie mini société qui s'y
trouvent il ya un infirmier un cuisinier
un spécialiste en communication des
ingénieurs des matelots des navigateurs
des photographes et vidéastes
il faut savoir que l'écrasante majorité
de l'équipage est bénévole et évidemment
ils ne comptent pas leurs heures
c'est assez impressionnant de voir tout
ce monde là réunis pour une seule et
même cause chaque membre joue un rôle
primordial au bon fonctionnement de
l'opération
mais pour comprendre pourquoi ils sont
là il faut comprendre ce chiffre de onze
mille trois cents dauphins morts alors
la demande à guillaume un membre de
l'équipage de nous expliquer là on est
sur le rapport des choix 2018 qui a été
fait par pélagie fait tous les dauphins
échouent tout compiler des annexions ça
et ils vont ainsi de sortir de la donnée
sur les raisons de ces choix les
analyser tout ça quoi ok donc c'est
factuel c'est factuel
c'est du scientifique et c'est un bilan
général de
la distribution annuelle des effectifs
d'échouage de cétacés sur littoral
français en gros c'est combien de
cétacés et ses chaussures del toro c'est
à dire que la moyenne qui était à je
prends voix 990 échouages de cétacés
c'est à dire des dauphins et des
baleines tout ce que tu veux et l
arrivée genre à 2013 1200 et le pire en
2007 1600 cétacés qui s'échouent sur les
plages quoi c'est pourquoi il s'échoue
sur l'épave
alors justement
le truc c'est que ce pélagie s'ils vont
les autopsier 60% des cas c'est des
filets que les autres ap la majorité
après tu peux avoir dans sa vie s'il ya
des traces klaschka les traces de file
en fait les finesses des traces et il
n'y a pas de traces quand tu les ouvre
en fait tu vois que les poumons ils ont
éclaté en gros il n'aura pas s'asphyxier
dans les filets chez un dauphin lavaud
respiration les volontaires ouais et
tant qu'il est sous l'eau son évent dans
cette ceinture par dessus de la tête à
son évangile s'ouvrira pas tant qu'il
est chaud et donc il est traîné dans le
filet de pêche pendant plusieurs heures
qui viennent au dauphin sound from iran
plongé de quelques quelques minutes en
fait c'est pas dauphin crs pas trois
heures sous l'eau c'est pas forcément
parce que c'est une espèce en voie de
disparition à les protéger parce que
c'est une espèce qui a une grande valeur
écologique
donc là on s'équipe parce que
on va aller voir ce qui se passe
s'ils sont empêchés sa vie est très très
chaudement
très imperméables ce qu'on va rester
immobile pendant plusieurs heures
peut-être 4,5 m
le but de la campagne dolphin by catch
est assez simple dès que les pêcheurs
commencent à remonter les filets il faut
embarquer sur les zodiac pour observer
la remontée pourquoi pour vérifier qu'il
n'y a pas de dauphin mort dans les
filets si c'est le cas il faut s'assurer
que les pêcheurs le déclare car c'est
comme ça que les scientifiques pourront
comprendre quels types de pêches fait le
plus de dégâts
alors on part sur le zodiaque et on
observe la remontée du filet qui dure
souvent jusqu'à 4 ou 5 heures
évidemment et ce moment des conditions
assez difficiles c'est un environnement
où il fait froid où il ya beaucoup de
vent le tout avec la caméra braquée sur
le filet au cas où un dauphin est
remonté mais ce jour là
heureusement aucun dauphin à l'horizon
contrairement au lendemain matin on a
donc notre autre bateau le clémentine
une excellent avec une paire de
chalutiers pélagiques la nique à la
remontée du matin là il avait une autre
femme mon fils est voilà ils sont juste
devant nous on va s'approcher un petit
peu on nourrir il trône pour voir si là
ils ont toujours le dauphin sur le coup
on à la gendarmerie maritime qui est
juste à côté qui peut accoucher
on a la marine qui est là bas aussi
qu'ils sont en stand by donc le
clémentina fut la première levée de
filet avec eux qu'ils avaient les pings
eur nok et répulsif acoustique qui sont
censé écarter les dauphins ils ont
expliqué à notre équipage que ça servait
à rien qu'ils soient là qu'ils avaient
les pinger que du coup il y avait pas de
problème ils prenaient pas de dauphin
etc
et puis voilà sur la route et du
matériel d'un dauphin en fils la
solution déjà c'est plus de transparence
et que aujourd'hui le milieu de la pêche
la musique est très opaque
il se passe beaucoup de choses mais on
n'en parle pas
donc donc nous ce qu'on demande et on
n'est pas les seuls c'est ce que m'ont
aussi les scientifiques c'est d'avoir
plus de transparence comme par exemple
installer des caméras sur les bateaux de
pêche parce que beaucoup de pêcheurs
refusent catégoriquement
ça se fait dans d'autres pays et ça
fonctionne très bien ça les effets très
positifs alors le but c'est pas deux
filmer l'intérieur du bateau et de voir
ceux qui trafiquent on s'en fiche
complètement
le but c'est de voir ce qui remonte dans
le filet et comme ça ça permet de voir
quels sont les prises accessoires et ça
permet de comprendre quels sont les
lieux les plus à risques quelles sont
les méthodes de pêche les plus à risque
donc au final tout le monde y est
gagnant y compris les pêcheurs parce
qu'ils se plaignent qu'on les accuse de
d'attraper des dauphins etc etc
s'il ya plus de transparence à ce moment
là on a une meilleure idée du phénomène
et là on peut trouver des solutions
moi je suis ici c'est parce que je vais
vraiment essayer de faire un maximum
pour protéger les océans est ce qu'ils
les animaux qui y vivent
parce que je pense qu'on à l'heure
actuelle on doit vraiment faire quelque
chose maintenant et j'espère vraiment
qu'il n'est pas trop tard donc c'est
pour ça moi je vais donner tout mon
temps et j'ai toute ma motivation pour
essayer faire bouger les choses pour
montrer aux gens qui s'y connaissent pas
ou qui sont pas sensibilisés à ce
problème alors montrez vraiment ce qui
se passe donc il est temps d'agir et de
faire quelque chose tous ensemble pour
essayer de sauver lisa sion le bateau
pour moi c'est vraiment une famille
quand j'ai ma famille bien sûr en
belgique mais le bateau si j'ai trouvé
ma deuxième famille si on leur montre
qu'on est dévouée tout ça on peut
apprendre et devenir professionnel ses
motivations
si on a mis en place les méthodes de
pêche qui sont destructrices c'est parce
qu'il ya une demande en poisson qui
explose on mange beaucoup trop de
poissons en france et ailleurs
sauf dans les pays où peut-être il en
aurait plus besoin aujourd'hui une
écrasante majorité des gens qui pêche
qui mangent du poisson pourrait très
bien s'en passer
donc il n'y a pas assez de poissons dans
l'océan pour répondre à cette demande en
poisson ya pas assez de poissons dans
l'océan pour nourrir tous les prédateurs
marins et tous les humains qui pourrait
se passer du poisson et qui en mangent
sans même y réfléchir
en fait aujourd'hui si on prend les
recommandations de l'om est donc
l'organisation mondiale pour la santé
sur la consommation poissons
donc c'est deux portions de poisson par
semaine on attend déjà le double de ce
que l'océan est capable de fournir en
poissons
sans compter le fait qu'on continue par
la fin tous les prédateurs marins
en fait nous on s'est rendu compte à
quel point les legends le grand public
peut être déconnecté de ce qui se passe
en l'air c'est quand on fait des
opérations de sensibilisation avec les
dauphins morts sur les places publiques
ça choque beaucoup de gens mais il y en
a beaucoup qui qui pensent que c'est un
faux dauphins ou qu'ils nous disent
qu'il n'y a pas de dauphin en france
alors qu'ils sont vraiment sur le pas de
notre porte donc on est complètement
déconnecté de sa et en même temps on se
rend pas compte que si l'océan meurent
nous mourrons tous d'un point de vue
utilitariste c'est aussi nous mêmes
qu'on essaye de sauver
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
dans la description pour soutenir sea
shepherd si jamais l'envié vous en prend
et nous on se retrouve très bientôt pour
une vidéo qui n'a absolument rien à voir
on va reparler des téléphones mais cette
fois je vous dire ce que j'ai dans le
mien love peace now